- C'est terrible, là,
puis je reconnais pas Montréal.
(sirène)
- La montée de la violence
armée à Montréal choque
parce que des jeunes
comme Meriem Boundaoui,
Jannai Dopwell, Thomas Trudel
ou Hani Ouahdi en ont payé
le prix fort.
Pour renverser la vapeur,
L'Anonyme, un organisme
de services sociaux,
a embauché deux pairs aidants,
d'anciens criminels repentis
pour aider les jeunes coincés
dans l'engrenage des gangs
de rue à s'en sortir grâceau pr.
SYLVIE BOIVIN,
directrice générale, L'Anonyme
- Eux arrivent avec quelque
chose qui est très fort
pour notre structure
et notre organisation
et ils apprennent dans
notre milieu, mais on apprend
beaucoup d'eux, aussi.
- Les pairs aidants suivent
des formations et des stages
auprès, notamment, d'organismes
communautaires et d'écoles
avant d'être déployés
sur le terrain, prêts
à ir auprès
de jeunes qui ont parfois
une carapace dure à percer.
Radio-Canada a choisi
de ne pas dévoiler
l'identité des pairs aidants
afin de ne pas nuire au lien
de confiance qu'ils établissent
avec les jeunes.
Père absent, besoin
d'appartenance à un groupe,
délinquance, allers-retours
entre la maison et le centet lee
jeunesse : les pairs aidants
qui ont rejoint les gangs de rue
avant l'âge de 15 ans
ne l'ont pas eu facile.
- J'ai fait comme
une rétrospection,
si on peut dire ça comme ça,
alors que je faisais
un séjitencier.
Je voyais ma vie défiler,
je... je me faisais plein de
questionnements : est-ce que
je vais passer toute ma vie...
derrière les barreaux,
à courir, à fuir, à regarder
derrière moi tout le temps?
Et ça m'a poussé à...
tranquillement, pas d'un seul
coup, mais ça m'a poussé
tranquillement à vouloir
prendre un autre chemin.
- Leur but aujourd'hui,
c'est que d'autres jeunes
n'empruntent pas le même
chemin qu'eux par le passé.
- J'ai vu mon grand frère
aller en prison. Euh... j'ai vu
mes amis se faire tirer dessus.
J'ai vu moi-même en centre
jeunesse et tout. C'est tout
un cercle vicieux qui faisait
en sorte qu'à un moment donné,
tu te dis : OK, mais qu'est-ce
que je fais avec ma vie?
- Une collaboration qui, selon
cet expert en gangs de rue,
leur permettra d'avoir
une approche unique auprès de
fermés aux interventions
traditionnelles.
RENÉ-ANDRÉ BRISEBOIS, Institut
univers. Jeunes en difficulté
- Le jeune va peut-être avoir
us grande ouverture
pour aborder certains sujets,
puisqu'il va comprendre que :
OK, lui, il a vécu un peu
la même chose, il sait de quoi
je parle. Donc çe pluse pluse ps
grande confiance et une plus
grande ouverture, aussi.
- Le gouvernement Legault
a récemment annoncé
un investissement de
52 millions de dollars en
prévention de la criminalité,
dont près de la moitié
est dédiée à Montréal,
où le problème est plus criant.
Une bole pour
des projets comme ACTES
et ses pairs aidants,
qui espèrent bien bénéficier
de cette aide financière.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada,